[Music]
good morning
everybody it is seven o'clock in the uk
welcome wherever you are watching us
right around the world this morning
something to smile about for england
fans this morning
as we look forward to the knockout
stages of euro
2020 but questions and concerns from top
health officials
after the government raised crowd
capacity at wembley to more than 60
000 for the semis and the final the
media minister john whittingdale will be
with us
very shortly indeed also this morning we
will be hearing from two legends
of english football david seaman and
john barnes to find out if they think
it's coming home also to come for you
our holidays
once again on the horizon as ministers
prepare to reveal their latest thoughts
on travel
protests are planned in cities across
the uk today
we'll speak to the head of british
travel agents and the leader of the
pilots union
about what they want from the government
it's wednesday the 23rd of june
ecstasy and agony concerns this morning
over an increase in crowd capacity at
wembley
as a scotland crash out and england head
to the euro 2020 knockouts
the good thing from our point of view i
think we you know we're still improving
delta plus the new strain of the indian
variant
is discovered in a handful of cases
what's going on
we're live in india and we'll ask the
world health organization too
inside britney's bedroom we travel to
the superstars home
town as she prepares to challenge her
father's control over her
in court
and pause for his predictions meet
achilles the oracle cat
who's been casting his bets on the euro
winners
and there's a northwest southeast divide
in the weather today plenty of sunshine
for southern parts
a little bit gray and rainy towards
those northwestern areas
to find out what's going to happen in
the next few days join me for the
weather details later
good morning england is marching on in
the euro so fans have something to smile
about but there's concerns this morning
over plans to increase crowd capacity at
wembley to more than 60 thousand
for the semis and the final the world
health organization believes it's a
risky game increasing crowd numbers in
countries where covey cases are rising
like here
england heading to the knockout stages
they beat the czech republic last night
but there were contrasting fortunes
north of the border where scotland
crashed out at hampden ender brady
reports
for england the excitement of knockout
football now beckons
for scotland the dream is over crushed
by croatia
at wembley england had to win against
the czech republic to top the group
raheem sterling's first half goal
proving to be the difference
between the two teams
[Applause]
calling mcgregor's goal drew scotland
leveller hamden park
the croatia came back at them time and
again
[Applause]
for steve clark this tournament has been
bittersweet
we've been looked as though we might get
something out of the game we had some
moments earlier where we we managed to
get
some football away managed to play
through them but not i think
overall croatia with a better team on
the night and sometimes you
you just have to accept that for gareth
southgate
it's job done and into the last 16.
whoever we play really really tough uh
opposition um but we've sort of known
that for 18 months we've known the route
uh through and the good thing from our
point of view i think we
you know we're still improving but kyo
saka is a local west london lad
he only came into the team when two
players were forced to isolate
due to culvert it's amazing i've played
here before and um
got a man of the match performance
before but that was about the fans and
about my family so tonight to have my
family and
of course the england fans in the
stadium it was it was really special and
it's a night i'll never forget it's been
confirmed that 60
000 fans will be here for the
semi-finals and final at wembley
uefa getting their wish we're going
through
and we're going to win this cup all the
other performances
the dutch the italians so much more
creativity
we we're we're we're not in the game
really
yeah i think we need to grow a lot more
confidence you know i think you know no
one's denying the capabilities there and
the potential is there but we need more
i think you know players need to just
not you know care so much
so england will be back here on tuesday
where they will face one
of france the reigning world champions
portugal the current european champions
are germany it is quite a choice
but england have yet to concede a goal
and will be confident of defeating
anyone
on home soil ender brady sky news
at wembley not everybody could of course
get into the stadium last night
plenty of fans in trafalgar square becky
cottrell
is there it was quite the event there
last night wasn't it
yeah trafalgar square is where nhs and
frontline workers from london
came out to watch the match yesterday
obviously fans want to get into the
stadium
england will be back at wembley on
tuesday they will be
facing one of the teams from the group
of death those international football
titans so the pressure really is
on for england now an announcement
from the british government that for the
semi-finals and the final over 60
000 fans will be able to get into
wembley
they will have to have proof proof that
they've been vaccinated
twice or they've had a negative covid
test but this has prompted talk at home
of special treatment for football okay
thanks so let's put that shall we to the
media minister john whittingdale
who's joining us now mr whittingdale
good morning to you thank you for
joining us this morning what's the
justification
for raising the numbers for the semis
and the final
at wembley well good morning and thank
you
for inviting me um i mean i think to
some extent it is the benefit
of uh our success with the vaccination
program we have been proceeding
cautiously i was
lucky enough to be at wembley last night
where obviously there was
a smaller number permitted that was part
of our
events research program and we're now
moving to the next stage
where for a number of events we will
increase the capacity
but at every stage we're obviously
listening to the scientific advice and
we won't do anything
uh that will put public health at risk
and even though the capacity is going up
people will still be required to
demonstrate that they've either had
two vaccinations or that they've had a
negative uh covet test
yeah but away from fifa officials being
allowed into the country quarantine
free and they will be at wembley the
world health organization is saying
they're quite anxious about the whole
idea
well we have listened very carefully to
our own scientific advisors they are
content that we can move to this next
stage um yes there will be some people
coming in but they will be coming in
to attend the game they'll be under the
strict
restrictions as to what else they can do
and we have measured these things very
carefully
and we won't do anything that we will
put our success at risk
but as i say i think we are now at the
stage where we can look forward to
some relaxation if this pilot works then
hopefully we can expand it
into course i want to talk about that if
i may the events
results program as it's called erp for
the benefit of my viewers
um so far there's been a series of mass
event trials including
the fa cup final at wembley of course um
the brits the snooker world
championships
what are the findings of that report
well the initial findings were very
encouraging
and we we're going to be publishing the
full analysis
uh before we take the next step which
hopefully we will be able to do
in july and we've said that we will make
that report public
but it's a complicated exercise it needs
a lot of
analysis and obviously we want to be
absolutely confident of the findings
before we publish
why is it complicated either lots of
people didn't get covered as a result of
going to these events or they did
well obviously that's that that's the
headline but you do actually need to
look and see um you know whether or not
there was transmission
um the age groups how how it appeared
that it was spread
um you know these are um technical
and complicated events which uh
are to test uh the success we have had
of containing the virus and to make sure
that
as we move to relax further we're not
going to put that at risk
and i think that people would expect us
to carry out a very thorough analysis
we've always made plain that we will
publish and we will publish before we
announce the next steps
yeah but this has been going on for ages
hasn't it mr whittingtail and she knew
who was there because they were
checked quite thoroughly before they
went to these events you knew what age
groups they were you knew whether
uh subsequently they had coveted or not
because they were tested
um why can't given that it was uh
successful
why can't things like theaters and other
events open up now
lord lord weber says um apparently the
report has recommended opening theaters
well i can completely understand why
lord lloyd webber would like to see
theaters right
we would all like to see theaters
reopened but we are proceeding
cautiously
we have selected a small number of
events as part of the
uh events results program and you know
we are now
looking at those findings and if they
are positive then i very much hope
that we will be able to move to step
four it has been delayed because
obviously
uh there was an increase in the numbers
particularly of the new delta variant
but we are extremely hopeful that uh
come july the 19th we will be able to
move step four
and that everybody will be able to go
back to the theater and you were going
to say the delta variant so i looked up
the figures
125 reported deaths uh the
week ending the 11th of june the lowest
in eight months and certainly that does
take into account
uh the delta variants so again i put it
to you
um the nightclub industry uh the theatre
industry so the festival industry is on
its knees
they need to see this report you have it
and you won't show it to them
we will share it to them we've said we
will publish the report we've always
been clear
we will publish the report before we
move to step four we will demonstrate to
people
the evidence and the analysis of the
results of the program
and the basis on which we have reached a
conclusion that it is i very much hope
safe to move to step four and you know
we have been through
a horrendous year or more now um the
last thing we want to do is throw away
the success we've had
it's only another couple of weeks the
chancellor has provided
okay okay okay okay we've got it we've
got it
19th of july you're going to publish the
report before then yeah
yes we've said we will publish it before
we reach decision on step four okay fine
uh talk to me about holiday uh
destinations uh where are where are we
as far as that is concerned looking at
the figures
our figures in the uk are much worse
than most of mainland europe and
malta are we expecting several european
countries to go onto the green list
later on in the week
well we've said that we will be looking
later in the week
to make revisions to the green list and
i hope that we can put more countries
onto it you know i quite understand why
people
want to go on their summer holidays i
would say to them that you can have a
great whole day in britain and i think a
very large number of people will decide
this year that that's what they will do
but having said that people
you know like to get away to the sun um
and
there are a number of countries on the
green list i hope that it will be
possible to
increase that number but that's
something which we will be looking at
as i say later in the week okay i'm just
looking at the figures as we're chatting
and uh malta has got one in a hundred
thousand poland
three and a hundred thousand germany
eight in a hundred thousand
italy twelve and a hundred 000 france 24
and 100 000 our latest figures were 93.7
in 100 000 here in the uk what on earth
is the justification
for not having european countries on the
green list
well that is just one of the measures
that you have to look at
um there are of course others we are way
ahead of any other country in europe in
terms of the proportion
of our population that are vaccinated
and that offers a degree of protection
and as we've seen
these figures can change quite quickly
you know we were sadly
uh forced to put portugal temporarily
back onto the amber list because of the
uh case rate there so you know these are
expert decisions by the scientists
they make recommendations to government
and it takes account of a range of
factors
um okay well i'm sure you understand and
appreciate the
frustration of the travel industry lots
of them are demonstrating later on today
they're also
planning to sue you you can understand
their frustration can't you
of course i can understand their
frustration not just of people
whose business is the holiday industry
but also
i know millions of people who you know
want to get away
and i very much hope that you know we
will soon be at a position where
that we will begin to return to
normality
i think international travel is going to
continue to be perhaps one of the more
challenging
areas in terms of resuming normal life
but we are all working towards that
nobody wants to force people to sit in
this country or
wants people not to be able to go to the
theater again
and we are moving in the right direction
um are you confident
that if people want to go overseas costa
del sol
or wherever this summer that they will
be able to
i'm certainly hopeful um that is
something which you know we are keeping
under constant review
as i say i hope very much that it will
be possible to put more countries
onto the green list i hope that it may
even be possible in due course
to relax or itself restrictions um for
people who for instance have had two
vaccinations but i mean these are things
which you know are being kept under a
constant examination
and when we feel it is safe to make
those changes
then we will do so yeah of course we've
been able to do that for
uefa and fifa officials haven't we
coming to the football david davis has
called that morally inconsistent
well we've always said that for you know
some people who are uh important
to players for instance we've heard
specifically
no of course not but we're talking you
know we're talking a very limited number
of people
who are coming in and they're also
subject still to uh quite significant
restrictions they're not just able to
come in and travel around britain and
they come in to attend
a match and then go away ken and
you know we we wouldn't have been able
to host um
the tournament at wembley if we hadn't
allowed the players and people
associated with the teams to come in to
do so
you are launching allowing chanting at
matches
particularly at wembley but seven people
can't sing hymns together inside
well i mean i you know we have said that
professional cars can now sing
people amateur choirs can sing outside
um
but you know as i say we are proceeding
cautiously i would i very much
understand that you know amateurs
um are very popular a lot of people
enjoy singing i quite enjoy singing
and i hope but we'll get to the point
where you know people can resume those
kinds of activities
um but you know i think most people
watching this will
feel that the government is right to
proceed cautiously and do nothing to
put at risk the huge success that we
have had in terms of beating this forest
trust me you wouldn't want to hear me
singing mr whittingdale a quick question
about channel 4
before i let you go to what question is
the answer
privatize channel 4
well there's been a huge transformation
in the way in which people
watch tv with a lot of new entrants
which is fantastic news for the viewer
you now have a choice between
sky and netflix and amazon and apple as
well as the traditional public service
broadcasters
channel 4 has a very special place
amongst the broadcasters
it has been hugely successful but with
that kind of competition coming on in
order to sustain it over the long term
we think it will need investment it will
need capital to invest in programming
and it is subject to really quite strict
limitations
whilst it is in public ownership so we
have said that it's the right time to
think about
you know a future model for the
ownership of channel 4 which will make
sure that it continues to go on
providing that very distinctive content
and serving the public service remit
which it has
way into the future why would you want
to get rid of it when it's had its best
financial year
last year ever well we don't want to get
rid of it we want to sustain it this is
about making sure that it has a
long-term future
in a very different world to the one
which most people are familiar with
[Music]
we are looking at the ownership
possibilities one of the
requirements i think over the coming
years is that
channel 4 needs to have access to the
kind of capital investment it is
you know in order to retain viewers you
do need investment in
good content and with some of the new
entrants
netflix and amazon they are spending
huge amounts more
than channel 4 is able to do and an
alternative ownership model
may make it uh possible for them to
access the kind of money
to continue to provide great programming
okay i'm being told that you have to go
just want to ask you very quickly how
was the football last night you were at
the stadium weren't you
i was there are some benefits of being a
dcms minister
obviously it was a great result i was
delighted that england won
you know i'm looking forward i don't
think i probably could manage to get
there again but i should certainly be
watching
uh the match next week and hopefully
we'll go all the way okay
fantastic thanks very much indeed
minister thank you
well if you don't take it from the
minister perhaps you'll take it from
paul the octopus remember he had an
astonishing record predicting winners in
the world cup well
he's got a rival for euro 2020 and that
is
achilles the oracle
cat from russia having a very good run
achilles he's already got two out of two
results correct which he does by
choosing and eating out
of a particular food bowl uh he's got a
way to go paul's run back in 2010 so i'm
correctly
guessed 12 out of 14
predictions supposed to be it's out of
both bowls it's a draw i don't know but
what achilles lacks in legs he's making
up for enthusiasm
he's uh keenly awaiting the next
prediction and another
two bowls of food
love it still to come on the programme
for you at 2028 the legend that is john
barnes will join me to tell us how far
he thinks
england can go in euro 2020
as news comes in from india of a new
strain of the delta variant we'll speak
to david navarro of the world health
organization
and travel workers have declared today a
day of protest with hundreds of
thousands of
jobs under threat we'll speak to the
association of british travel agents
and the leader of the pilots union just
after 8 o'clock
before all of that though there's a new
variant of concern in india called delta
plus although currently found in just a
handful of cases
what are the scientists making of it
let's find out uh
what it's all about neville lazarus are
joining us in delhi this morning hello
to you neville tell us about delta plus
morning okay well the delta plus variant
has has been seen or discovered in
three of the states in maharashtra
madhya pradesh and
kerala and it's just a handful of cases
at the moment
22 in all but the government taking no
chances they've made a containment zone
or on these where these clusters
or where the variant has been discovered
and
uh they have said that this is more
transmissible than
just the delta uh the variant and it is
a big concern
and the prime minister his scientific
advisor all
warning the country of a third wave
which
they say that it is imminent in the next
few weeks we've seen the devastating
effects of the second wave
in the months of april and may on india
where almost 10 million
cases and over 150 000 deaths took place
in the same period
of of of of the second wave
and now with this coming there is a big
concern out here
of uh the new delta plus variant okay
good to talk to you thanks very much
thank you
uh quick look at the latest covid
figures for you showing a continuing
rise in the number of cases
in the uk this is how it's looking 11
625 new coronavirus cases reported in
the latest data that's the highest
number
since the 19th of february 27 more
deaths were reported
total number of people who've died
within 28 days
of a positive test is now more than 128
000.
other news for you now and more than 150
employees have been sacked or resigned
from a hospital in houston
for refusing to get a covet vaccine it
follows a ruling by a judge allowing
workers to be sacked if they refuse a
jab
the houston methodist hospital was the
first major u.s healthcare provider
to make vaccines mandatory for workers
you're saying the travel industry
calling on the government to safely
reopen
travel and provide more financial
support to help the sector travel agents
pilots
aviation workers and cabin crew are
among
thousands of people taking part in a day
of action to pressure the government
into reopening international tourism
a new 50-pound banknote featuring the
portrait of
alan turing has entered circulation
the code breaker famous for his wartime
work at bletchley park was born
on this day 109 years ago
her life has gripped the world strings
of smash hits a very public breakdown
and a very quick marriage and a fight
with her dad
over who controls her life it reaches
its climax today
britney spears is preparing to tell a
court why she should be back in charge
of her own life
our u.s correspondent greg milam went to
her hometown
a warning this report contains flash
photography
down here we have
the furniture that she had in her
growing up room
they're very proud of britney spears in
her hometown of kentwood in louisiana
her life of course has been quite a
journey from here
and who controls that life now is the
subject of intense speculation
out of all the fame and adulation her
stories become a cautionary tale for
young celebrities
this is free britney 102. while this
documentary raised questions about the
13 years she's spent subject
to illegal conservatorship she's been
largely silent
for the podcasters who probe the dark
side of her story
hearing her in court is a big moment my
immediate hope for her is that she gets
to see
what she wants to say and that she's
listened to ultimately i do hope that
she's able to be autonomous
the terms for a conservatorship is that
someone's unable to clothe feed or
shelter themselves
and britney spears can you know do all
of those things
so it's just an extremely upsetting
situation she's in i think that that's
why so many people are interested in it
lawyers say she does have some control
she had the opportunity to request a
termination
of the conservatorship and so far we
have not seen her ask for that we know
that she's unhappy with her dad
being in the role of conservator and she
wants that person removed out
i think she should have what she wants
a whole movement's been born out of
britney's legal affairs
and they say it now goes way beyond her
our first and main focus is to get
brittany free from these restraints but
also
to raise awareness about this this
threat that's
out there as far as probate
conservatorships that come in and
take over a person's life and and their
money it could happen to any of us
we've been told as fans it's none of our
business to stay out of it
and that's why it's continued for so
long i think brittany means a lot to a
lot of people
that's certainly true for myself i think
that
just she has been judged so harshly
by society i believe that britney will
be free
one day one way or another the fans look
to her social media posts
for clues as to what she really thinks
her father
says the conservatorship protects her
she herself has requested this court
hearing
in her own words she will at last a
voyage into space can take its toll
on an astronaut's health but you might
be more surprised to hear the scale
scientists have gone to to try to
improve the trip
like this dozens of baby squid have been
sent into space so scientists can see
how they react to the journey and
potentially solve health problems
faced by astronauts the 128 hawaiian
bobtail squid was sent into orbit on a
spacex mission
to the international space center
earlier this month
believe it or not the squid the squadron
squid will help scientists understand
why long space flights affect an
astronaut's
immune system come a long way since
the russians put a dog in space haven't
we do you remember what his name was
do you remember what that dog's name was
i'll tell you in a minute
after the weather here's joe good
morning joe
good morning well it's looking a little
bit um ropey out there certainly for
northern and western parts down towards
the south it's
lovely clear skies sunshine and it shall
be warm as well
let's take a look at all the detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you yes lovely and
sunny through many southern parts of the
country
was chilly to start off with though
temperatures back to around three to
five degrees celsius
milder up towards the north and west and
you can see why there's more in the way
of cloud
and patchy light rain now there's not a
huge amount of us
but what there is is starting to work
its way southward so really
what we start the day with is roughly
what we end the day with
apart from these central areas here and
this is where we'll see a bit of change
as cloud starts to increase over parts
of wales later on parts of the southwest
and you can see still
some pockets of rain and drizzle around
although there's quite a lot of clouds
eastern parts of scotland northeastern
parts of
scotland also seeing some sunshine now
and that sunshine is likely to remain
through eastern parts
temperatures around 22-23 degrees
celsius that says 73 degrees fahrenheit
into this evening and again that cloud
just slips a little further south
and continues overnight but it never
quite reaches east anglia and the
southeast
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the name of the dog seems to have
escaped most of the team this morning
was in fact
laker yep you're right went into a space
on sputnik
2 november 1957 first living creature
sent into space didn't come back
still to come on the programme for you
this morning the england legend himself
john barnes will be with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
we're enormous explosion has just come
down
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked they were right
[Music]
we hear shotguns being fired
withdrawn it's so so hot
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the importance of climate change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address the
climate impact
in my campaign or in advocacy work i
work entirely with young people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
hello again you're watching uh the
breakfast program here on sky
media and data minister john
whittingdale has defended the
decision to allow thousands of uefa
officials and vip fans to travel to
london for the finals
of euro 2020 it's planned to increase
the number of fans at wembley
for the semi-finals and the final to
more than 60 thousand
three-quarters of the stadium's capacity
mr whittingdale told us kovid
restrictions would only be relaxed when
it's safe to do so
yes there will be some people coming in
but they will be coming in
to attend the game they'll be under the
strict
restrictions as to what else they can do
and we have measured these things very
carefully
and we won't do anything that we will
put our success at risk
but as i say i think we are now at the
stage where we can look forward to
some relaxation if this pilot works then
hopefully we can expand it
into course labour's shadow defense
secretary john healy is with us now good
morning good morning good morning um
so important people can come into this
country to watch the football
but we can't allow people to travel to
ambulance countries at the moment and
not quarantine when they come back
thoughts on that wrong um wrong and
too much of what we've seen from this
government really one rule for
important people one rule for them and
one rule for the rest
it was the way that dominant cubbings
thought it was okay for him to
break covert rules that were being
imposed by his government on the rest
and
we've seen this time and time from
ministers that just don't play by the
sort of rules we expect
of our british government and our
british ministers but how do you feel
about um
relaxing the rules so that uh brits can
go to european countries looking at the
latest numbers as far as covid
cases are concerned ours are
significantly higher than lots of
european countries
i think we're off the pace on this many
other european countries are putting in
place
arrangements for people who've been
double jabbed they're putting in place
arrangements for
confirmation or vaccine passports and
we've still got a confusion within
government over what to do
we've clearly got to relax the
restrictions as soon as we can we've got
to have measures in place to make sure
that we can manage this for the long
term
so that doesn't must involve allowing us
to travel
but it's also got to involve proper
support for those that must isolate if
they've been in contact
with someone with covid and finally
getting our tests and trace systems
sorted out so that we can
see this led from the local level where
we know from the experience of the last
few months that it's councils that can
best do that
and how does labour feel about the um
the trials that have been going ahead
for
uh mass events like um the fa cup final
uh the uh crucible and and the snooker
championships world championships
there we still haven't seen the results
of that the minister said that we would
but one wonders when because
as as i said to him the nighttime
industry is on its needs and it needs
the results
yeah a good thing the government did
these trials
i live in rotherham i'm from rotherham
the sheffield crucible was the first
event
with a full crowd and we want to see
that um but if this is a trial
we need to see the results that's what
the government pledged that's what we've
been pressing in parliament
because the public and the really the
the experts need to know where they
stand and
if we've got the evidence let's look at
it and government and the rest of us can
make proper judgments off the back of
that and has labor been pressing for
that
indeed okay and what's been the response
uh stonewall
um a promise made conduct the trial
publish the results lead a debate make
the decisions required and instead we've
got delay
we've got a stone walling and
you've got to ask well what are the
results
have these trials been done properly and
how can we draw the conclusions we need
because
people want to get back to be able to do
things whether it's music festivals
events nightclubs and they certainly
want to be able to move more freely
around the country and go on holiday
in the meantime does labour support the
increase in crowd capacity at wembley
for the
um finals and the semi-finals of the
euros
hard to make a judgment of that without
seeing the evidence and the technical
detail but if we can do it safely
let's do it let's have the biggest
possible crowd especially for the next
game when
we've either got to play germany or
possibly
um france uh or portugal um
we don't want any of them really do we
but probably less likely to be portugal
uh
okay okay well i'll take your word uh
for that we've got uh we've got a
feature that we're doing today
on um achilles the cat that makes all
the predictions apparently she's very
very he's very very good at it
so let's see what he predicts for us but
as far as um the rules and regulations
are concerned i wonder if i could
ask you in a bit more detail about that
because i did also press the minister on
the fact that there can be chanting at
wembley
but seven people in in a amateur
chorister group
can't gather inside to sing together
well
i mean the longer this goes on and the
longer we have really no clear-cut
decisions and
a proper map through this and for
managing
covert of the long term from the
government the more confusion and
contradictions we have and
you know for people who can't sing
together uh
that really matters and it i think
when government isn't giving the
clear-cut rules
isn't giving the lead isn't setting out
the plan people will make these
decisions for themselves and
increasingly
the government is making itself
irrelevant to us properly managing this
covid uh pandemic and the
uh the future infections irrelevant
that's a strong word why do you say that
because i think all of us in many ways
are
first of all trying to understand what
the rules really are now
secondly making judgments in our own
lives
about the risks we'll take for ourselves
and the families and those are our loved
ones
and without the decisions we should
expect from government
the delay in making the clear cut
decisions the confusion often
and then the really unacceptable
sort of one rule for the vips uh
the one rule for the rest of us if we
want to travel abroad
as we saw from john whittingdale this
morning it's leaving the country in a
limbo without the leadership that we
should expect and have a right to expect
from our government ministers and our
prime minister
two things they are um set on um is
selling channel four
and not um allowing the scottish
parliament to um to have an indie ref
two thoughts on that
well for my money just as the uh
scottish nationalists said we had a
referendum
uh to settle that question of the uk
union for a generation uh and on channel
4 this is a
great part of our british broadcasting
public service
and creative drive right across the
world
it's got a mandate to be innovative it's
got a mandate to be alternative it's
part of our
proud world-beating british broadcasting
system
and i don't want to see it put into
foreign hands
but if it's so fabulous then somebody
will want to snap it up and make money
out of it and
why should the british people be at
least part funding that when they're
already funding the bbc would be the
response i suppose from the government
its value at the moment is it's its
ownership is uh
not a question that then directs the
programming it makes
part of the mix of our rich british
broadcasting
uh i don't see a case for changing that
i do fear that it goes into the
ownership of some
big multinational uh foreign group then
we could see
a an influence as we've seen in other
parts of the media where ownership
starts to distort
the sort of editorial decisions the
creative programming
and we lose what's very special i must
counter that and say that doesn't happen
at sky news and we're owned by a
foreign company indeed um
you you may say that and you couldn't
pass it
good on you for sticking to that
position and sticking to your editorial
independence
yeah and we certainly do that we're ring
fenced at sky news as
you know um as far as funding is
concerned for the next 10 years and
finally the yacht the royal yacht
what do we think it's going ahead
apparently the ministry of defense
has decided that they will pay for it
her majesty doesn't want it the
government says it's a great idea
because it will it showcases us on a
world stage well
the defense secretary is appearing
before the defense committee in the
commons today there's some big questions
on this
it's not a royal yacht it's not for the
royal family it's a vanity project for
the prime minister
and when the threats facing the uk are
growing
the defense department should be
investing in defense not building a boat
for boris johnson
okay i've thought of something else i
just wanted to ask you i forgot sorry
um batley and spen if you lose next
thursday does your leader have to
consider his position
well let's not get ahead of ourselves
i'd prefer to wait to the election
results rather than the opinion of
pollsters
uh certainly my experience of being in
batley in the campaigning encountering
i've done there suggests it's all to
play for
and that's what we're doing okay and if
you lose
well let's just not get ahead of
ourselves let's wait for the
judgment and the result of the election
but
you know i think with kia stammer you
know we've got somebody
who is a man who could be a prime
minister from day
one he's a man of integrity compassion
uh competence the very qualities that
british people expect of their
government and their ministers and they
certainly don't see
in boris johnson and i campaigned also
in the by-election last week in cheshire
and amisham and the reason that many
tory voters
were there did you was that the reason
that many tory voters moved against the
party is they don't have a prime
minister they don't have a government
that they can respect
they certainly could with kierstarma and
they could with labour in government
okay so next friday morning a week on
friday you'll come and talk to us will
you down the line or wherever
about the results in batley and spend
okay if you want me on your program i'm
always available hey there you go
convict somebody make sure we get a cab
for him thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot we appreciate it just a
reminder if you want to catch up
on any of our interviews here on the
programme
or watch this again you can by going
online of course
skynews.com in addition to that
if you would like to you can watch the
interviews on twitter
as well either at sky news or at k
burley
tamara is here good morning thoughts
well uh labour blaming the government
for the confusion about all the
different guidance which has seen
um thousands and thousands of football
fans
uh going to the stadium and even more
going to be there for the semi-finals
and the finals
60 000 fans going to be able to pile in
there now we
we hear that 75 capacity and they say
it's all going to be done in a very safe
way
this is part of the government's events
research program which will tell us
about the spread
of covered at big events but of course
galling for the entertainment industry
for festivals
that are being cancelled because they
say they couldn't get a place on this
program
and yet big sporting events could so
i think for the next three or four weeks
a lot could be lost in terms of the
entertainment industry
and while they wait for more clarity
from government i did press the uh media
minister about when we were going to see
the results of this program so because
then theaters may be able to reopen or
whatever
he's only said before step four as in
the end of all restrictions which we now
expect to be
on the 19th of july mps were pointing
out
in parliament yesterday that they've
been doing this since
april and may and we haven't heard
anything official even though the
culture secretary
actually said in a newspaper interview a
few weeks ago that out of 58 000 people
who've attended
all these events that they're
researching only 15
have had covered but apart from that
line in a newspaper interview we haven't
seen any of the data yet so mp's saying
why can't we have a look at it for
ourselves
okay for now thanks a lot tamara thank
you well as we've been discussing
england heading to the knockouts for
euro 2020
we want to know i know you're asking at
home this morning what does the former
england player john barnes think about
it well luckily enough we've got him
with us now hello to you john
good morning jay how are you i am great
thank you i love that painting behind
you talk to me
about the football how do you think
england is doing so far we are through
but it's not been scintillating has it
well the main things that we're through
and we haven't conceded a goal because
of course in england
we love to um over emphasize how
fantastic we are when we play well and
then when we
don't play so well we see how terrible
we are we're a very good side um we had
a good
first game against croatia not so good
second game against
um scotland and of course would be czech
republic last night
good first half average second half but
the thing is we're through we haven't
conceded a goal
we're not scoring many goals but let's
see what happens in the um in the
knockout phases
as to who we get yeah both girls um
scored by sterling of course is he your
player
so far of the tournament is concerned
he's not my player at the tournament
he's my player of england because we're
gonna have only scored two goals i mean
there are other
there are other teams italy have scored
seven or eight goals
germany looks strong so i don't think
any of the england players so far the
players of the tournament
but he's been obviously our shining
light but we're waiting for harry kane
to
catch fire because we're going to need
him the further we go in the competition
yeah because look who we might be facing
next talk to us about that
well that's the thing with the uh the
new format of three teams going through
it could be anyone
um of of germany france
or portugal um which would be any one of
them would be difficult but we're hoping
for hungary to bring a surprise and and
if they can beat germany it could be
hungry that's what we want
so um we've got a difficult one if it's
one of those three
but as gary southgate says if you want
to win the tournament you have to play
everyone and of course while it can be
better to play them in the final or
later on you know we
we have to play whoever is put in front
of us who do we not want in the next
game out of those
three i would want france i think france
are my favorites um as much as you
wouldn't really want to play germany
necessarily or portugal but out of those
three
i think france on the team i wouldn't
want to play okay um
gary southgate yesterday was talking
about the absence of ben chilwell and
mason mount of course they had to uh
quarantine
after coming into contact with a player
from scotland who
was covered positive he described it as
a bizarre situation
and full of contradictions what are your
thoughts
well um it was strange um not so much
okay
them isolating because before the game
they shook his hand and gave him a bit
of a
hug a little bit of a hug but for the
scottish players not having to isolate
the strange because of course they would
have been addressing with him
they would have celebrated after the
great results against england i'm sure
they would have hugged
um so not so much that they had to
isolate as much as
as much as they shook his hand and gave
him a bit of a cuddle in my opinion
i'm not a scientist i don't know how the
virus spreads necessarily
that seemed a bit strange but for them
to have to isolate and the scottish did
not
that seemed a bit strange okay and what
about um having 75
capacity or um crowd at wembley do you
have a view on that
well of course the view i have is that
fantastic from a plane point of view
that you want a crowd there
as to the safety aspect of things i'm
not once again i don't know
um as i'm not a scientist but i do know
the the issue whereby certain people are
saying
how can we go to restaurants but they
can go to football or something when
i'll go to the theater
but if you go to football you can't
please everybody um but i would like to
trust them enough
for them to as we've seen in um one of
the countries i think it was
hungry where it's a full stadium um
there are there are countries whereby
they are allowing certain amounts of
people to go back so as to whether it
should be
three quarters full or 5 000 or 10 000
or 20 000
i i don't know but it's good to see that
that people are getting back into
football stadiums okay
and your prediction for the cup are you
saying france or do you think england
can do it
well i'm i'm saying france um
i'm but i'm hoping for england not to
play the middle next round and maybe we
could have a france england final uh
let's see who england are playing then
if i come back on and and it's france
then he can ask me then
i will that's exactly what i'll do
that's something else we've booked for
wednesday we're sorting out our guests
already for next week thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot
you're welcome um the uk government says
it's planning to allow as we said 60 000
plus fans into wembley for the semi
finals but is it safe
or sensible with numbers of kobe cases
rising want to talk about that
in more detail with david nabarro's
special envoy on covid19 for the world
health
organization and chair of global health
at imperial college hello tues lovely to
see you
um i'm sure you're a football fan
morning morning you're a football fan
but is it a good idea to have so many
fans
uh at wembley
of course there are multiple sides to
this
if i'm talking to you just as a public
health doctor
i'm going to have to say that there are
real questions to be
asked because there is rising incidents
in the uk
and we really do know that when you
mingle people together
you're more likely to get spread but as
a citizen
i'm also thinking that it's time
for us all to start to work out how
we're going to get on with our lives
even though this virus is in our midst
and
we can't just stop doing everything
because
uh we're scared instead i'll tell you
what we have to do okay we have to
learn how to pick up signs that this
virus is picking up in an area
and then we have to know very clearly
what's got to be done
so that we don't end up with an
explosive outbreak that kills a lot of
people
and that's the thing that i ask
everybody to do
for themselves uh for their local
authorities
and nationally to concentrate on the
steps we need to have in place
to maintain defenses against the virus
to stop it welling up more and more
and that's going to be the life to come
at least until there's enough vaccine
and enough certainty to be sure that
vaccination will protect us
right now we can't say that and what
does that look like
for you is it uh people being double
jabbed and then is it people getting
these tests that they can
from the government website and maybe
testing twice a week what what do you
suggest
well there's one other part that i'm
going to have to say
you see the virus is continuing to
change
it's mutating and it forms
new types of virus that have different
capacities to infect and also
they do seem to be able to start
breaking past the defense that's there
from the vaccines
and so as well as using vaccine as part
of our defense
we're going to have to continue by
keeping a bit of a distance from each
other and
and i'm going to suggest that the
physical distancing part of one meter
plus
and mask wearing will be necessary
particularly in places
where there's a lot of virus we can't
just simply
ignore that so we've got to keep the
precautions in place we've got to have
really good test trace and isolate
systems that can pick up people with
disease
and uh get everybody isolated if they
need to be
and at the same time we will have to
continue with the vaccination program
and it will include boosters
so are you saying that people who are
working in offices
should still wear masks and be more than
a meter apart
there will be a need for every single
workplace
to be asking uh is it right
that we stop wearing masks and stop
maintaining distance
because that's the way you prevent
people from getting infected
and that's the key to stopping big
spikes building up
uh i personally am okay about
trying to find ways to get groups
together again i'm okay
about trying to restart the economy
because that's what has to happen
but i'm also saying the virus is still
in our midst and the virus is mutating
so we have to go
on being careful about it and i am
advocating
continued physical distancing continued
mask wearing
for the time being including in
countries where there's a lot of
vaccination
how are you feeling dr david about the
delta plus
variant that we're hearing about it's
only a handful of cases at this stage
but it is being picked up
yes and that issue of variance is what
we are watching
all over the world they are going to go
on coming
we will go from delta to lambda and then
on to the
other greek letters that's inevitable
and some of these variants will be
troublesome
they will be able to break through the
vaccine
related protection in a few people and
that will cause problems
i'm basically saying variants are going
to go on coming
that's part of life we need to pick them
up fast we need to move quickly if we
see them
in spa in a certain location and we need
to
build the management of variants into
what we call our kobit ready strategy
which is going to be the pattern for the
foreseeable future and how are you
feeling dr david about people
flying around the world
uh you know we really need to be careful
about this
uh only absolutely essential travel now
essential can be essential for emotional
reasons as well as essential for work
reasons
but essential really matters just it's
not
yet the time for unrestricted travel to
start
there are too many risks uh i believe
and i think that the possibility of
initiating another major explosive
outbreak because of a
an event in a particular location that's
done for leisure
it's too serious so i'm basically
suggesting
keep being keep being aware of this
virus and keep working hard to avoid it
and don't do don't do shortcuts because
just because we want to be strong in the
face of the virus doesn't mean that it
uh curls up and goes away no it can come
back with a vengeance so
keep recognizing it's there keep
behaving carefully
and and don't do things that you don't
need to do
dr david we are out of time but of
course i need to ask about a little
person before i let you go how's he
doing
yeah well uh otto the one that i haven't
yet
met i was hoping to meet him this
weekend but it's really difficult to
travel from um
france to the uk and back again at the
moment all sorts of rules and they
change
so i fear that i i'm having to make do
with zooms but thanks to your
uh very careful attention i would say
all my grandchildren are doing really
well
and they send you their best and they
say welcome back
after you're you're happy that's lovely
dr davey thank you so much and i'm glad
they're all doing well hopefully you'll
be able to see them
soon thanks a lot thank you i hope you
do thank you
thank you um stay tuned for more here on
skype